ليص عدد الجنود سحب
الويه واخيرا لواء من شمال قطاع غزه ما
الذي يعنيه بالعلم
العسكري يعني تنسحب القوات عاده اخي حسن
لاسباب عديده السبب
الاول عدم تحقيق الاهداف التي كلفت بها
هذه القوات وخاصه اذا ما اخذت زياده عن
الوقت المحدد لها واذا منيت بخسائر كبيره
وتدنت الكفاءه القتاليه عند الجنود ضباط
و تضعف الروح المعنويه والقتاليه يصبح لا
جدوى من وجودهم في مسرح العمليات وهذا ما
يعني اعتقد السبب الاول السبب
الثاني هو تقليص عدد القوات من اجل تقليص
عدد الخسائر لانه الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعد
يتحمل هذا الكم وهذا الحجم من الخسائر
اليوميه سواء كانت
بارواح الجنود والضباط او بالمعدات
القتاليه او حتى بالروح المعنويه حينما
نتحدث عن 30,000 حاله صدمه نفسيه عند
الجنود الاسرائيليين يتم معالجتهم اعتقد
انه هذه ايضا من الاسباب والسبب الثالث
وهو ما تدعي به
اسرائيل انها تريد ان تقلص عدد القوات من
اجل التقليص نفسه يعني بمعنى انها اتخذت
قرارا لتقليص وهذا انا بتقديري يعني ربما
رساله للامريكي الذي يطلب منها دائما
وابدا تقليص عدد القوات والانتقال الى
مرحله ثالثه لو لو بقيت هذه الالويه حتى
لو ازداد عدد القوات الاسرائيليه في قطاع
غزه ما الذي بامكان الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
يقوم به اكثر مما قام به حتى
الان يعني اخي حسن لن ابالغ ان قلت لك ان
ما يقوم به الجيش الاسرائيلي هو عباره عن
تدريب على يد المقاتلين الفلسطينيين اشبعو
اشبعو في اسرائيل بمناورات بت تدريباتهم
بالسيناريوهات التي حملت عناوين كلها ثبتت
فشلها وهزيمتها ما يجري على ارض الواقع هي
تدريب تدريب هؤلاء الجنود والضباط على
فنون القتال من قبل المقاومين الفلسطينيين
لانه ما يجري على ارض الواقع حقيقه
المقاومين الفلسطينيين يطبقون وينفذون
بجداره فن القتال في المناطق المبنيه وفن
استخدام اساليب حرب الفدائيين في حين ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يتقن ايا من فنون
القتال لا على مستوى الجنود النظاميين ولا
على مستوى حرب الشوارع او حرب المدن التي
تدربوا عليها كثيرا لقد اقاموا اقاموا في
قطاع في في صحراء النقب مدينه تشابه مدينه
غزه او بقراها بمخيمات
وقضوا اشهر كثيره وهم يتدربون عليها ولكن
انا بتقديري فرق كبير ما بين تدريبهم
النظري وتطبيقهم العملي في مواجهه هؤلاء
الابطال المقاومين الفلسطينيين الذين
يلقنهم كل يوم دروسا في فنون القتال ماذا
رايت في هذه المشاهد التي بثت قبل قليل وا
اكثر من
مره يعني رايت عديد عديد اخي حسن عديد من
الدروس عديد من العبر هذه الشجاعه
المنقطعه النظير يعني نحن نشاهد الفيلم
الصوت والصوره ولكن لا نعرف الصعاب
والمغامره والبسالة التي يتمتع بها هؤلاء
المقاتلين حينما يتقدمون ويغامر هذه تحتاج
الى كفاءه قتاليه الى تنسيق وتعاون الى
معنويات عاليه الى تحكم
اي بطبيعه الارض الى الاقتراب من الهدف
والتعريض للخطر ومن ثم التسديد واصابه
الهدف وفوق كل ذلك يصور بالصوت والصوره
يعني هناك اكثر من رسائل رساله اولا
الاقدام والشجاعه المعنويات العالى
الكفاءه القتاليه اي الاصابه ومن ثم
الرساله الاعلاميه وهي توازي هذا الصاروخ
الذي يفجر الدبابه انا اعتقد انه هذا
الفيلم يبث على وسائل كثيره وخاصه الجبهه
الداخليه الاسرائيليه التي تنتظر معلومات
وتنتظر اي انجازات من هذا الجيش ل لتقول
لهم هذه الصواريخ هذه القذائف هذه الكمائن
بان جيشكم مه زوم في قطاع غزه وانه لن
يحقق اي هدف وخاصه رساله لاولئك
المستوطنين الذين ينتظرون عودتهم الى
المستوطنات بعد تامين الجيش الامن والامان
لهم وهذا طبعا ينفي ينفي كل ادعاءات
القياده الاسرائيليه بانهم قد انجزوا
اهدافا على الارض